let's talk about geometric
geometric sequences
geometric sequences which is a class of
sequences where we start at some number
then each successive number is the
previous number multiplied by the same
thing so what am i talking about well
let's multiply a times r
and then i'm going to get a r
i'm going to get a r let's multiply it
times but to get the third term let's
multiply the second term times r and
then what am i going to have well i'm
going to have a
that's a different shade of yellow i'm
going to have a r squared multiply by r
again you're going to get a r to the
third power and you just keep on going
like that and this is the way i've
denoted this this is an infinite
geometric sequence we just keep going on
and on and on and on
and with different ways we can denote it
we can denote it explicitly we could say
that
our sequence is a sub n starting with
the first term going all the way to
infinity
with
with a sub n equaling well we see an a
here for any term it's going to be a
times
r and just to be clear this right over
here a is the same thing as a times r to
the 0th power
r to the 0 is just 1. this this second
term is a r to the first power the third
term is a r to the third power it looks
like the nth term is going to be a r to
the n minus 1 power so a
r to the n minus 1. and you could verify
it if you want the second term you're
going to say a times r to the 2 minus 1
a times r to the first power it works
out
this is defining it explicitly we could
also define it recursively we could say
a sub n
from n equals 1 to infinity
with
with
a sub 1 being equal to a that's the base
case a sub 1 is equal to a a r to the 0
is just a
and or we could say 4
4 n
equals 1 and then we could say a
and i don't even have to really write
that because we're making it very clear
that a sub 1 is equal to a
and then we could say a sub n is equal
to the previous term a sub n minus 1
times r
for
n is greater than or equal to 2. so this
is saying look our first term is going
to be a that right over there is a a r
to the 0 is just a
and then each successive term is going
to be the previous term times r which is
exactly what we did over there so let's
look at some geometric sequences
so i could have a geometric sequence
like this i could have
a sub n
n is equal to 1
to infinity
with
with let's say a sub n is equal to let's
say our first term is
i don't know let's say it is equal to
20 and then r the
the number that we're multiplying to get
each successive term let's say it's
equal to one-half one-half to the n
minus one so what would this sequence
actually look like well let's think
about it the first term is 20. if you
say if your n is one this is going to be
one half to the zeroth power so it's
just going to be one times 20. so the
first term is 20 and then each time
we're multiplying by what well here each
time we're multiplying by one-half so
it's going to be 20 times one-half is 10
10 times one-half is five
five times one-half is 2.5 actually let
me just write that as a fraction is five
halves five halves times one-half is
five-fourths and you can just keep going
on and on and on this is a geometric
sequence
now let me give you another sequence and
tell me if it is geometric
so let's say i started one
and so then i'm going to go to 2
and then i'm going to go to 6
and then i'm going to go to
let me see what i want to do i want to
go to
24
then i could go to
120 and i go on and on and on is this a
geometric sequence
let's think about what's going on to go
from 1 to 2 i multiplied i multiplied by
two to go from two to six i multiplied
by three to go from six
to twenty-four i multiplied i multiplied
by four
so i'm always multiplying not by the
same amount you have to multiply by the
same amount in order for it to be a
geometric sequence here i'm multiplying
it by a different amount so this
sequence that i just that i just
constructed
has the form i have my first term
and then my second term is going to be
two times two times my first term
and then my third one is going to be
third time three times my second term so
three times two times a
my fourth one is four times the third
term so four times three times two
times a and we go on and on and on
so this sequence which is not a
geometric sequence we can still define
it explicitly we could say that
it's the set or the it's the sequence a
sub n from n equals 1 to infinity
with
a sub n being equal to let's see the
fourth one is essentially 4 factorial
times a well actually if we look at this
particular these particular numbers our
a is 1. so this is actually let me write
this as 1. this is 2 times 1 this is 3
times 2 times 1. this is 4 times three
times two times one and so eight a sub n
is just equal to
is just equal to n
n factorial this
this right over here which is not a
geometric sequence describes exactly the
sequence right over here just to get
some practice with regard here we've
defined it explicitly but we could also
define it recursively we could also say
do it in white we could also say that a
sub n
a sub n
takes us from n equals 1 to infinity
with
a sub 1 or maybe at a sub 1 is equal to
1 that's our first term and then each
successive term is going to be equal to
the previous term
times n
so the second term is equal to the
previous term times two the nth term is
going to be the previous term times n so
this is another valid way
valid way of defining it